[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime up
drawer and today I'm going through 10
Saitama facts if you want to see more
one punch man videos make sure to
serious punch that like button and
subscribe to let me know and without
further ado let's jump into the facts
fact number one site the masked story is
similar to his creators own story one is
the alias of the creator of the original
webcomic for one punch man then later
the manga artist Yusuke Murata did the
illustrations for the manga style remake
the anime is more heavily based off of
the latter manga version but it all
started with one's webcomic the webcomic
started out as a hobby he always did it
for fun like Saitama is a hero for fun
saitama's frugal Ness is also taken from
one's real life before the success of
one punch man one had a problem he
wanted to work full-time on web comics
and manga but he needed money so he
decided to get a job for a year however
his plan was to not goof around and save
up as much money as he possibly could
and quit this way the year after that he
wouldn't have to bother with a part-time
job and could focus all of his time on
his art he planned to spend 365 days
doing nothing but comics and if that
didn't lead anywhere he'd give up and
get one of those real jobs that people
are always talking about luckily as with
Saitama his hobby ended up actually
turning into a profession that paid so
that he could keep doing it nevertheless
for a while he had to live very frugally
just like Saitama who was also jobless
before receiving his hero salary Saitama
would spend as little as possible and
live off of vegetables given to him by
people he saved so that he could keep
doing what he loved for as long as
possible and it ended up working out for
both of them I love this idea of living
frugally so that you can do what you
love everyday
forget the fancy restaurants the sports
cars and the nice clothes that people
buy to impress others we don't actually
need that much to survive and I respect
people who are willing to rough it if it
means that they get to do what they love
every
I was definitely prepared for that when
I started to work on YouTube which I
also started doing for fun because I
think that doing what you love even if
it means having less materialistic
things always beats out working around
the clock doing something you hate and
living in a big house that you barely
get to enjoy because your job drains you
of all your time and energy so in
addition to being hilarious one punch
man is also packed with serious wisdom
which if followed can totally help you
live a happier and more meaningful life
fact number two like one before he
became jobless and lived off of his
savings Sytsma had a regular job he
worked at a convenience store in classic
Saitama fashion when a man pointed a
knife at Saitama all he did was wonder
where the barcode was commenting on this
one has said that even since long ago
Saitama has had that unperturbed
character that we've come to love so
much back number three Saitama has
become too strong to be an ideal hero
according to the creator of one punch
man after three years of doing 100
push-ups every day 100 sit-ups every day
100 squats every day running 10
kilometers every day eating 3 meals
every day including a banana for
breakfast never using heating in the
winter or conditioning in the summer and
persevering even when it was hard and he
was vomiting blood Saitama managed to
break his human limiter which is
supposed to lemon how strong one can get
as a result he lost his hair and became
a man who could pretty much beat anyone
with a single punch and it usually
doesn't even take a serious punch sounds
good on paper but the reality is that
Saitama has gotten too strong for his
own good one has said in an interview
that he believes that the coolest thing
about a hero is that he or she stands up
against someone who seems stronger than
that one says it's easy to be a hero
when you know you're stronger than your
enemy but what is truly impressive is if
you can stand up to a bad guy who is
clearly stronger than you one feels like
that mentality and zeal to rush in to
help even when you know you're weaker is
what defines a hero he says that Saitama
wants that zeal as well but he
taken away from him because he became so
strong in this sense itemised envious of
people like Moomin rider who bravely
rush into a fight with opponents who are
clearly way stronger than they are
that's right ladies and gentlemen Moomin
rider is the ideal hero that the world
desperately needs back number four
Saitama was purposely made to be
different from other heroes in fact one
came up with Saitama simplistic design
in response to how many cool-looking
heroes there were out there think about
it heroes usually have cool hairstyles
expressions and names but Saitama is
bald has a signature derp face and his
hero name is bald cape the illustrator
of the manga mu data pointed out that
sytem is similar to Goku from Dragon
Ball they both have a detached easygoing
this and when things are looking
hopeless the moment they show up you
know things are going to be okay which
is true enough but one also made one
punch man to be different from Shawn and
like Dragonball instead of focusing on a
character's growth one wanted to see
what happens if the hero starts in peak
condition Goku is constantly being
pushed to get stronger than he was
before
while no one has been able to push
Saitama to even use his current full
power not to mention that Super Saiyan
Goku probably has the coolest hair known
to man I think it is exactly because one
punch man challenges all these
conventions that we love it so much
after all you wouldn't see Batman way
more concerned about losing his wallet
than saving the world fact number 5 you
may already know that mob cycle 101 and
one punch man are both made by the same
creator 1 but what you may not have
picked up on are all the references the
two works have made to each other for
instance we can see at one point erotica
Reagan from mob cycle 100 is using a
picture of Saitama for his cellphone
display picture in mob cycle chapter 80
point 5 we see site to me again this
time in a dream
lastly Saitama and mob the two main
characters of each series share the same
blank expression most of the time as
well however as one mentioned in an
interview the two main characters are
actually opposites according to one in
contrast to one punch man the main guy
in mob cycle 100 is emotionally
weak and delicate so the side characters
act as a support for him one goes on to
say that the series are kind of opposite
but they are both extremes making them
easier to create so despite the fact
that they are both powerful and share
the same blank expression one succeeded
in making them different and unique
characters at the same time back number
six as we know one of the ongoing jokes
in one punch man is that no one except a
handful of people really appreciate how
insanely strong Saitama is this is
reflecting the hero associations ratings
for Saitama even though Saitama is
clearly a better fighter than jenos the
hero Association gave generals the best
ranking and s-class ranking while they
gave Saitama a pretty embarrassing
c-class ranking the hero association
gave him the following scores a 10 out
of 10 and stamina a 1 out of 10 and
intelligence a 1 out of 10 in justice a
10 out of 10 in endurance a 10 out of 10
in power a 1 out of 10 in popularity a 3
out of 10 in effectiveness and an
inconclusive question mark in fighting
ability this gives him a total score of
36 out of 80 for comparisons sake and to
show how little the hero Association
actually knows King the lovable but
phoney hero scored a 10 in every
category giving him a perfect score of
80 out of 80 generals went ahead and
gave Saitama his own scores which were
as follows he 15 plus in stamina he
foreign intelligence a 15 plus injustice
he fifteen plus an endurance a 15 plus
in power a 1 in popularity a 15 plus an
effectiveness and a 15 plus and fighting
ability so to say that his true ability
is off the charts is an understatement
this would give Saitama a final score of
95 out of 80 even if we ignore all those
pluses fact number 7 and now we get to
the character popularity poll for the
one punch man manga in the series
another ongoing joke is that Saitama is
not nearly as popular as he should be as
mentioned the hero association and jenos
agree that he scores a 1 out of 10 the
lowest possible score in popularity
ironically though in the real-life
popularity poll Saitama came in 1st
place and that's not all his younger
self came in 10th place
in the first webcomic popularity poll
sytem also came in first followed by the
great Moomin rider thus even if
fictional people have yet to realize
sites of his greatness at least we the
readers and viewers rightly recognized
it back number eight saitama's voice
actor in the Japanese is the 29 year old
Makoto Furukawa
he was also bondrée tada the main
character from golden time it's a
completely different style of show that
one punch man it's a comedy slash drama
slash romance but I loved it and highly
recommend it koko kaga is just the
cutest cook ever bonus fact Makoto flew
Kawa has the same last name as one of my
all-time favorite anime characters
Nagisa fukagawa from Clannad and you
should definitely check that one out too
fact number nine site the most English
voice actors a 28 year old max Mittleman
he also voiced King in seven deadly sins
and coasts a edema in your lie in April
two other anime that you should check
out if you have it you can even find max
in one's other anime Mob cycle 100 back
number 10 in lieu of fact number 10 I
usually do and will do again a lightning
round where I tried to fit as many facts
as I can in a relatively short period of
time because who doesn't like bonus
facts who doesn't like surpassing limits
like my boy Saitama so without further
ado here's some consecutive facts
serious series in the manga sytem escape
was read at first and then later changed
to white sytem is 25 years old
175 centimeters or 5 foot 9 inches tall
and weighs 70 kilograms or 154 pounds
size the mole was partially inspired by
a children's superhero from Japan called
Anpanman second most hero costume is
very similar just some of the colors are
switched around
they're both bald superheroes and their
names Anpanman and one punch man sound
very similar in the Japanese one says
that running his size of a specialty but
he isn't good at other sports many
people think that secum is weak at first
glance but Boros and carnage Kabuto can
immediately sense his insane power not
only did one choose to draw a bald
average looking superhero because the
world is already full of cool-looking
superheroes he chose to do it because he
believes that a hero's coolness comes
from the spirit and
their looks how they look is actually
not important according to one one has
said that his favorite character is
Saitama followed by King and lastly the
name Saitama comes from an actual place
in Japan one first started drawing the
series one punch man inside Touma
prefecture Japan and that is it for
today's video let me know if you liked
it by smashing that like button if you
haven't make sure to subscribe and ring
that notification bell so you don't miss
any new videos let me know if you want
to see these kinds of videos for other
one-punch main characters if so let me
know who you would like to see done next
in the comments thanks for watching and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]